den aufreger habe ich seit 18 monaten
und jetzt spitze sich noch mal besonders
zu wir erwachsene wir leben eigentlich
wieder ein weitgehend normales leben
zumindest dann wenn sie geimpft sind
lassen wir hier wahrscheinlich alle
unsere kinder erleben immer noch an den
schulen einen beklemmenden
ausnahmezustand die schulschließung
waren das eine die schulschließungen in
den drei lockdown viel länger als andere
europäische länder eine oecd studie hat
jetzt gerade wieder ergeben doppelt so
lang waren in deutschland die schulen
geschlossen wie im schnitt der anderen
europäischen länder viele hatten in der
zweiten dritten werden überhaupt nicht
mehr die schule dicht wir haben es
gemacht obwohl wir wussten was wir damit
anrichten jetzt sind die schulen auf
aber das ist immer noch weit davon
entfernt das ist ein ein kindgerechter
lebensraumes schule ist ja nicht nur
lernort sondern auch lebensort und die
maßnahmen in den schulen tragen
teilweise obsessive züge die kinder
müssen stundenlang maske tragen kleine
sechsjährige siebenjährige die meisten
von denen gehen ja eine
nachmittagsbetreuung und wenn man das
zusammen nimmt müssen die sechs sieben
acht stunden am stück die maske tragen
dass mut in dir fast keinem erwachsenen
zu und bei kinder nehmen wir es
achselzuckend hin oder jetzt gerade die
einschulungen die stattgefunden bei wie
vielen einschulungen durften dürften die
geimpften großeltern nicht dabei sein
teilweise sogar nur ein elternteil
obwohl die obwohl die feier mit abstand
mit wasser auf dem hof stattfand das
trägt fanatische züge inzwischen an den
schulen und was jetzt berlin gemacht hat
das ist ja der absolute die absolute
krönung dass man tatsächlich zweig so
machen wollte dass kinder die sich gar
nicht impfen lassen können
ausgeschlossen sind von
restaurantbesuchen von veranstaltung vom
theater man hat inzwischen korrigiert
aber dass man überhaupt auf die idee
gekommen ist mein verdacht es ja man hat
sich das nicht bewusst überlegt man hat
kinder hier in berlin schlicht vergessen
und das ist leider symptomatisch für den
umgang mit kindern der gesamten pandemie
habe frische ich kann wirklich jeden
satz unterschreiben
aber das problem begann ja nicht in
berlin auch wenn berlin das jetzt
erstmal wirklich besonders schrecklich
wie auch sonst hingekriegt hat aber wenn
sie von fanatischen zügen sprechen
müssen sie dann nicht konsequent über
das kanzleramt sprechen also war das
kanzleramt das immer wieder schuld für
schulschließungen geworben hat wenn es
um schule öffnung ging haben sie gesagt
nee wir sind ja nicht für
bildungspolitik verantwortlich bildung
ist ländersache
um schulschließungen ging da die
kanzlerin gerne auch mal die mpk
wutentbrannt verlassen um die anderen
ministerpräsidenten unter druck zu
setzen weil das cdu geführte kanzleramt
über ein braun über angela merkel
christina spielweise in der tat da gab
es auch in der cdu und der union sehr
unterschiedliche positionen und ich habe
da immer sehr klar stellung bezogen und
man kann sagen dass es vor allen dingen
die ministerpräsidenten armin laschet
und volker bouffier waren die
dagegengehalten haben auch union die
haben gesagt es geht hier nicht um den
härtesten kurs gerade bei gegen kindern
und jugendlichen sondern es geht hier um
einen angemessenen kurs und wir müssen
abwägen und wir müssen auch sehen was
wir den kindern damit antun und es ist
auch kein zufall dass jetzt zb in meinem
bundesland volker bouffier hessen jetzt
gesagt hat wir schaffen die masken
pflicht am platz ab dass armin laschet
nordrhein-westfalen dass die die ersten
waren die bei der quarantäne gesagt
haben wir schicken nicht mehr ganz
klassen in corona ich will nicht
behaupten dass das so eindeutig
parteipolitisch ist aber ich würde schon
sagen die linken parteien bei den grünen
ist nur witze stark weil der spd
aufnehmen so saskia esken und pezzoni
sei der beim armin laschet karl der
steht für einen liberalen
verhältnismäßigen kurs in der tat mit
markus söder mit dem cs und korrosive
gase wenn ich nicht einverstanden gerade
insbesondere gegenüber kindern und
jugendlichen
ein konzept zu entwickeln wie berlin das
jetzt getan hat ist nicht etwas was man
innerhalb von ein zwei stunden herstellt
sondern es gibt kopf es gibt leute die
hochbezahlten profis die tagelang
vielleicht auch momente der liga zwei
gibt es wenig brachten sogar gebe ich
ihnen recht aber dann kinder nach 18
monaten ein weltweiter corona krise wo
die studios das habe ich in diesem
studio gesagt und das will ich immer
wieder sagen es gibt so verheerende
folgen von lock down south kinder man
kann nicht sprache und soziale kontakte
herstellen und lernen mit maske vor
allem bei den allen klar und dann ein
konzept herzustellen ohne wirklich an
den kindern mitzudenken das ist wirklich
ein skandal was aber ich hätte es nicht
für möglich gehalten wenn man mir das
vor zwei jahren ich habe ja schon als
familienministerin immer den vorwurf
gehört deutschland ist ein
kinderfreundliches land das hielte ich
für dummes gerede ich habe und ich ich
hätte mir das niemals vorstellen können
dass wenn der pandemie gerade mit
kindern und jugendlichen sollen sie
haben leider keine lobby die werden
nicht wählen es wäre unser aller aufgabe
gewesen dass vielleicht noch mehr nach
vorne zu bringen auf die straße zu
tragen wo war der aufstand der eltern
eigentlich wo war eigentlich der
aufstand der lehrer auch ja früher ihre
kinder für ihre schüler und schülerinnen
gekämpft haben und nicht nur für ihre
eigenen interesse für ihre eigene
gesundheit um die es da immer gh wir
machen uns das jetzt wieder ein bisschen
einfach im nachhinein das heißt so so zu
definieren als hätten alles gewusst
schon immer über cupid und dergleichen
als es begann war ja alles im lot down
maschinen standen still vw porsche ag
den ersten lok naja aber immer genau das
sagt mir ab aber es ist richtig dass die
kinder mit den ganz alten in den in den
heimen diejenigen waren die die größte
last zu tragen hatten und leider bei den
kindern immer noch haben mein jüngster
sohn genau das gleiche in der halb sechs
acht stunden am tag diese maske auf
teilweise musste er sogar sport machen
oder muss er noch sport machen mit der
maske und das macht man mit elf jahre
und ihr sind getestet und dann werden
wir wieder so einige tests und messen
das dort vorher aber die große frage ist
für mich ja auch wie kommen wir da raus
also wo ist denn hier irgendwann mal
ende davon und wann und womit wenn wir
zu 70 prozent getestet sind es 80
prozent ja wann und wer sagt uns ja und
da gehört zur bitteren wahrheit
natürlich auch schon 1 dazu es ist nicht
nur die politik
ich hab mir mal angeguckt die die
vorschriften der länder für die
einschulungsfeier die waren gar nicht so
rigoros aber viele schulleiter oder auch
viele örtliche gesundheitsämter haben
dann nochmal drei schärfe gerade drauf
gesetzt und so kamen dann diese absurden
szenen zustande oft wird es hält man
hätte haben uns angewöhnt den kurs der
quasi jegliches risiko vermeidet für ein
besonders verantwortungsvollen kurs zu
halten und alle sind dann ganz angetan
das ist gerade der kurs der nicht
verantwortung übernimmt der schulleiter
der sagt ich schließe die geimpften
großeltern aus ich mache das ganze
draußen mit maske mit abstand der kann
vielleicht abends ruhig schlafen und
sagen da ist garantiert nichts passiert
und wenn man mir keinen vorwurf machen
aber der hat gerade keine verantwortung
genommen verantwortung übernimmt wenn da
das unter angemessenen bedingungen macht
und damit auch mini risiko in kauf nimmt
das ist verantwortung den kindern es ist
niemandem vorzuwerfen der in der politik
ist der regierungssitzung keine kinder
hat das klar ganz klar ich glaube
trotzdem und sage diese entscheidungen
werden nicht getroffen worden wenn wir
am kabinettstisch mehr normale eltern
gehabt hätten die einfach normalen
alltag haben die wissen wie beschissen
homeschooling gelaufen ist und die
wissen wie schlecht es den kindern geht
wenn die über monate zu hause das glaube
ich überhaupt nicht also ich glaube wir
haben einfach auf die falschen leute
gehört und klar die bundeskanzlerin hat
keine kinder
kanzleramts chef helge braun hat keine
kinder jens spahn hat keine kinder aber
wenn man sich mal die politiker quer
beet anschaut wir haben über markus
söder gesprochen er hat kinder und er
hat anfangs für schulschließungen
überhaupt erst gesorgt und dann kamen
halt die virologen ins spiel und ich
würde sagen wir haben auf die falschen
gehört aber wir haben vor allem zu sehr
auf sie gehört aus biologischer sicht
macht es natürlich sinn alles mögliche
dicht zu machen was irgendwie viren
verbreitet aber darum soll es ja nicht
gehen und wir wollen ja irgendwie dann
noch die gesellschaft am leben erhalten
und die kanzlerin hat sich halt gerne
das büro mit biologen voll gesetzt und
hat halt auf die gehört und die haben
wir die rekursen berechnet und einmal
gesagt jawohl schulen dicht die kinder
niesen ja oft und die husten ja oft aber
zur wahrheit gehört natürlich auch dass
es auch unter den eltern eine ich würde
sagen denkste minderheit 20 30 aber die
können den können die maßnahme auch
nicht hart genug seien die haben sich
davon die glauben quasi inzwischen ist
wirklich ihre kinder gefährdet sind
dabei hat man die schulschließungen
gemacht weil man gesagt hat die schulen
treiben das infektionsgeschehen es geht
um die älteren aber die glauben
inzwischen dass ihre kinder gefährdet
seien werden jetzt beispiel von unserem
amilcar lauterbach auch immer weiter
angetrieben da sind ängste ich würde
sagen irrationale ängste wiederum darum
glück und sehr aggressiv brauche ich
noch eltern die ihre kinder sogar
vorwürfe machen wenn europa oder oma
krank werden das hat auch markus zu da
getan in einem interview mit den kindern
dass er sagt schuss schulschließung ist
schlimm aber wenn europa steht noch
schlimmer und das kann man nicht nach so
verteile ich ehrlicherweise ich glaube
das hat er hier sogar ein bild gemacht
wir haben den ausweg leider aus dieser
krise noch nicht gefunden nachdem wir
weiter suchen sind uns aber bei dem
thema einig in der runde und umso
absurder das weiterhin schulschließungen
drohend in vielen bundesländern
[Musik]